Matthew McConaughey that would be a good
time for me to take my shirt off
interstellar 2 hours and 45 minutes
later still don't know what the [ __ ]
word means okay so this is the next
chapter in the Christopher Nolan legacy
we know this is a movie that's gonna be
[ __ ] debated up the wazoo but there's
a couple of things I want to acknowledge
first I really think this film needs a
second viewing find out my girlfriend's
mom thinks I might be gay so I'm going
to light the fire on the match that's
not a phrase wow I am really wasting
time this one was so detailed so grand
so [ __ ] Nolan epic so sighs hi that
there's no way you can grasp it all in
just one viewing unless you're a jackass
lastly this is gonna be a little
difficult to review because the trailer
did a good job and not revealing much so
I feel like if I say more than the
trailer it might be like a spoiler but I
will be doing a spoiler review with
Jerry so keep a lookout for that [ __ ]
wasting time so yeah the story is but we
all thought it would be it's based off
all these like scientific theories like
wormholes and quantum physics and
physical energy attraction environments
oh [ __ ] with the earth I still litter by
the way it's all told and very
impressive detail and I'm too stupid to
know if these theories are Nolan made up
or are there actual theories they
managed to take all the information
until a really interesting movie
interesting is the word I use overall to
describe it I would say there's a lot of
fantastic things in the story for sure
like overall yes it's a great movie but
like [ __ ] Rotten Tomatoes has been
saying I totally agree it's certainly
flawed and on a personal level I just
wasn't fully
engaged in it the whole time only
because there's just a lot of
information to keep up with and I don't
know when I want a movie to be perfect
my guards like up a little bit so it's
the kind of thing where like as more
time goes on I like it more and more
another reason why I might have been
fully into Russ is because partly it's a
lot of [ __ ] information to keep up
with like there's a lot of themes and
theories in this film and words I've
never heard before and there are times
where I felt like they were stretching
out the script a bit too much you don't
want to stretch it out too much you know
what I mean the penis like Norlin wanted
to take us some like this grand
adventure
astronaut turn farmer who's becoming an
astronaut again was to go through a
wormhole to find a planet so us humans
on earth can live somewhere else
it's Christopher Nolan so yeah we know
it's gonna be [ __ ] insane and we know
there's gonna be a lot of story but what
I really did appreciate out this film it
cuts past a lot of [ __ ] to get to
the story even faster the actual
adventure and there is a lot of familiar
science-fiction elements but because of
the kind of tone and world established
it's more grounded it seems more
realistic it seems like this kid we
could somehow create this today but
something about the emotional impact
that was obvious the director wanted us
to feel I was not feeling it I mean like
don't get me wrong there are great
characters Matthew McConaughey Wow
remember when he sucked dude I love this
performance he's actually the thing I
walked away really thinking about with
this film I mean come on it's Matthew
McConaughey like this is a difficult
movie to carry and he [ __ ] did it
it's a very emotionally driven
performance and although I wasn't fully
emotionally grasped I still almost cried
a couple times because of how [ __ ]
raw McConaughey was man I mean behaving
like a little [ __ ] in the theaters you
know [ __ ] crime movies she it's just
like oh this crazy science fiction [ __ ]
is going on and he looks like he really
believes all of it it's [ __ ] awesome
I definitely would not have been as
interested in this film if it wasn't for
a really strong performance from him
Anne Hathaway is also great I thought
she was a lesbian at first in this movie
and in real life apparently she's not in
either of them her role is more subtle
than McConaughey's McConaughey like
there's definitely not as much focused
on her emotional journey and there's a
couple of moments we're not in terms of
performance like her performance was
[ __ ] perfect the character itself she
actually like pissed me off a couple of
times she managed to do it like one
scene after the next and it was like
dude you pissed me off twice now and
strike three [ __ ] and you're out
together like two scenes where she was
annoying but other than that she's
[ __ ] perfect Michael King he's like
fantastic in this film like if I were to
review every Nolan movie I wouldn't
mention Michael Caine every time because
I'm used to him kind of just stepping in
and being the wise older guy for the
protagonist but she is like in this
movie but they gave him more than just
being the wise guy hey yo Michael Caine
you can feel the hope in this character
but you also feel the doubt in this
character wow there's a very big plot
turner not gonna give it away that's
revealed through his character and when
that plot turn happens it it it makes
the movie better it's a good plot room
that's all the Minnesota Jessica
Chastain not gonna reveal who she places
it would ruin the film for you she yes
is awesome and she's very hot prior to
me getting a girlfriend I have thoughts
of her like hugging her baby never sex
stuff with her don't believe in that I
can't go into too much better but she's
fantastic in the film she's another
character who's living off hope and
doubt as well I mean there were like one
or two times where I thought it was a
little overdramatic but like 95% of it
she's pretty damn good but back to the
story an adventure felt like the movie
gravity kind of made me immune to like a
lot of the space danger
I kept thinking gravity made all those
fears better but this movie aims more to
like fascinate you so you take you on an
adventure to live vicariously as an
explorer so yeah it's like different
than gravity so it's actually not fair
to compare it don't know why did that
not look like an [ __ ] but anyway yeah
while I was like interested in
everything going on I was never truly
like moved by it air quotes lay a sauce
on IMAX by the way it is the only way
you should watch this [ __ ] movie they
shot like a third or maybe two-thirds
actually of this movie in IMAX cameras
and it's like the perfect [ __ ] movie
to shoot with IMAX cameras you're in
space and there's no green screen used
in this movie it looks [ __ ]
incredible like especially the wormhole
sequences Wow
I'm pretty sure that is the intention of
how no one really wants you to watch
this movie is IMAX so if you want scene
in its purest form its
Jesus Christ form you watch it on IMAX
I'm acting like I max is behind me but
I'm pointing to nothing actually people
dead that's what that is
yeah the cinematography [ __ ] amazing
the score by Hans Zimmer I don't know I
did a bad banging voice in my opinion is
some of his best work he's ever done it
was fantastic Julie pretty much all the
technical stuff was all [ __ ] great but
like I said this might be just because
it was my first experience with it I
feel like with a second viewing I could
just sit back and more easily enjoy the
movie because I never was really scared
I always feel like everything was gonna
be okay I was never on the edge of my
seat the edge of the seat phrase trying
does it make sense to me because when
something is like really intense usually
we're sitting back you imagine a theater
but everyone at the edge of their seat
it will look stupid but the film is
still epic and I loved it in a lot of
ways
there's actors in it that are great that
I had didn't even mention in this review
I mean there's still time for me to but
I'm not going to designs and visuals
they're perfect
I just feel whatever flaws this movie
has the greatness is what you're gonna
walk away thinking of unless your
analytical filmmaking douchebag who
[ __ ] goes to schools like CSUN or
something another thing I can never
write [ __ ] like that movies this is too
hard it sounds like a [ __ ] homework
assignment at college and there are very
few people who are ambitious enough to
write something like that and are
creative enough to write something like
it so you got to just appreciate the
[ __ ] ambition overall let me get
straight to the point here all in all I
gotta say
interstellar got it super stellar right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for interstellar why don't you go
ahead comment below and tell me if
Matthew McConaughey released a picture
of his penis would you look it up male
or female answer the question like I
said earlier doing a spoiler review with
Jerry so check that out and if you want
to see more episodes of
straight-to-the-point you can click this
button right here see this is called
promoting oh and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews or videos is out
go ahead and click on this button by my
dick to subscribe that's right dick let
me tell you something about this little
engineer every time he's about to make
love with the ladies he does it in such
a stellar way you might even say in her
stellar these jokes get worse and worse
as time goes on